- Have you ever asked
yourself the question,
why haven't I done the things I wanted to?
Do not listen to the naysayers.
Purpose is that hidden seed of greatness.
Stop procrastinating.
Focus on your goal.
Nothing, absolutely nothing is impossible.
Watch your words.
They become your actions.
Watch your actions.
They become your habit.
- Hello Believe Nation.
My name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe and
I believe that entrepreneurs
will solve all of the
world's major problems.
So to help on your journey today,
we're going to learn from
empowerment specialist, Cindy Trimm,
and my take on your top
ten rules of success.
Rule number one is my personal favorite
and I love to know which
one you guys like the best.
As always, as you're watching,
if you hear something
that really resonates with you,
please leave it in the comments below.
Put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired.
You might win a prize as well.
Also, when you write it
down, it's much more likely
to stick for yourself as well.
Enjoy.
- Evaluate the why.
The why!
Yep, the why.
Have you ever asked yourself the question,
why haven't I done the things I wanted to?
Have you ever wondered
why others seem to get
the breaks in life and you
are stuck in a dead-end job,
a marriage that was over a long time ago,
a condition that is debilitating you
physically, emotionally, mentally?
Why haven't you realized your dream
or why did you give up
your personal power?
And why are feeling as if
you're a victim of circumstance?
And why do you consider yourself
a statistic, a demographic,
that other people are able
to benefit from but you can't
benefit from your own
product, a brand called you?
Why do you stay in that relationship
any way that frustrates you?
Why do you keep eating
when you know the steps
that you have to take
in order to be healthy?
I think there's one reason
and that is because you or someone else
has convinced you that
this is as good as it gets.
Why did you buy into that lie that success
and happiness are just for storybooks?
Or there is no happy ever after?
And if it's not one thing, it's another.
Why have you given up your dreams anyway?
Why have you given up your personal power
so that someone else
can decide your destiny?
Why have done this?
I believe that right now
you could be closer to
your breakthrough when you understand
that I also am in the same
position when I recognized
that God was drawing me to a secret place.
Wow!
Doctor Trimm.
Really?
I mean, I thought you
were going to come out
blazing with this big revelation.
It is big.
Because if you do the same,
you're going to get the same.
Sometimes you've got to center yourself
by taking some me moments.
Most of us take those me
moments on the telephone
with people who don't
know where they're going,
and then you're asking them how to
get to where you want to go.
If people don't know where they're going,
they can not help you to find out
how to get where you're going.
So I'm going to challenge you today.
I'm going to challenge you
to have a Jacob experience.
Jacob had to leave his family.
He had to leave the familiar.
It was for a short time.
He had to take some me
moments and wrestle.
He wrestled with himself.
He wrestled with the why.
Then I think also many of
us are afraid of aloneness
because we get aloneness
mixed up with loneliness.
There is a difference, you know.
Loneliness is the absence of people.
Aloneness is the absence of purpose.
This is the big why.
If you know the why, then
you can overcome any how.
You can forever change
the quality of your life.
The life that you lead by
the words that you speak.
Have you ever felt that you were trapped
in a cycle and a struggle of lack?
Well, you can get off
of that merry-go-round
of poverty, sickness, and
depression, and you can do it now.
When you change your words,
you will change your life.
One of the things that I found out
and the mistake that I made
in my life back in the day,
I kept talking about the
things that I didn't want.
I don't want to be poor.
I don't want this.
I don't want that.
Talking about and decreeing
what you don't want
doesn't bring to you what you want.
This is why many of us are
caught in these kinds of storms.
We have health storms, financial
storms, relational storms.
Maybe some of what is going
on is not happening to us.
Could it be that it may be
self-fulfilled prophesy?
Negative words bring
about negative results.
Positive words, healthy
words, successful words,
prosperous words will do exactly that.
It will bring health.
It will bring happiness.
It will bring success, and
it will bring prosperity.
I want to challenge you with one word.
The word that is most important
for any of us to have.
It starts with a c, I call it the c word.
It's that big word, courage.
All of us need an extra dose of courage.
I remember very clearly, and as I think
I can still feel the
butterflies in my stomach
and my stomach turning,
I was 15 years old.
I was in England.
They said, we are going
to show you how to abseil.
It looks so easy from
where I was standing.
I said, "I can ace that."
Until I got to that high
point on the mountain.
They put me, they harnessed
me up and they said go.
All of a sudden, the butterflies show up.
I have absolutely no courage.
Every ounce of "I can do
it" was drained out of me.
When I look down to the bottom
and I was trying to figure out,
I have never done this,
how am I going to get
from the top to the bottom?
It started with putting one
foot in front of the other.
Was I shaking?
Absolutely.
I even had a tear coming down my eye.
But with some coaching and
with a lot of cheering,
I tell you, I learned how to abseil.
To me, courage is not saying
that you don't have fear.
It's not saying that
you don't have anxiety.
I had to face my fear.
I had to feel it and
I had to do it anyway.
That's what courage is all about.
You ask yourself, can I really do this?
Can I really go back to school?
Can I really heal after a broken marriage?
Can I really go on?
We all ask those questions sometimes,
especially if we've been through a storm.
A financial storm, an emotional storm,
a relational storm, or
even a health storm.
When those winds are
blowing, it seems as if
we're going to capsize in a sea of fear.
But hang on for one minute.
Life is made up of storms.
I've learned from sailing
that it all depends
on how you adjust your sails.
To me, riding through the
storms, getting courage,
starts right here and right here.
Do not listen to the naysayers.
If you are going to have a breakthrough,
you've got to be able to
silence the negative voices.
That's the next step and
that's the next secret.
Many of us have too many
people speaking into our ears.
I just call these people abortionists.
So you've got to be careful.
Your dreams, your visions, your desires,
especially those that have been God-given.
I want you to pursue them.
I want you to believe that
all things are possible.
It is possible for you
to go back to school.
It is possible for you to
heal your relationship.
It is possible for you
to go at life alone.
It is possible.
Have you ever felt powerless?
Does it seem like you've
lost control of your life
or like your life may be
spiraling out of orbit.
Or maybe it feels like everyone else
around you is successful or prosperous
but it just hasn't happened to you yet.
Well, I want you to
discover how to get the most
of out of every single day of your life.
I want you to regain that confidence
and control that you once had.
And I want you to be able to
squeeze every drop of life
out of every single hour at every second
out of every single moment.
I want you to know what it
feels like to get up out of bed
every single morning excited and energized
and ready to take on the whole world.
You might ask, okay, calm
it down a little bit.
How am I going to do that?
How am I going to shake
off that powerless feeling?
I promise you right here, you
will have victory over this
when you get an understanding
of your true purpose.
Purpose is that hidden seed of greatness.
When you know your purpose,
your life will finally
come right into focus.
Listen.
I woke up this morning excited.
In fact, I wake up
every single day excited
because I know my life has direction
and I know where I'm going.
Purpose is the why, that
big why for you being alive.
When you find your why,
the when, the what,
the how takes care of themselves.
When you discover your purpose,
you will act decisively,
you will accomplish your goals.
You're going to be able to feel alive.
You're going to make right wise choices.
You're going to know what to say no to.
Knowing what to say no
to gives you the ability
to say yes what you should say yes to.
You want to say yes to the right things.
So when we talk about
purpose, it is actually
one of the most important
conversations we can ever have.
So many people are living life
based on someone else's purpose.
Why would you want to be a refrigerator
if God has called you be a blender.
Don't even think about being a blender
if God has called you to be a microwave.
You should not even want to be a microwave
if you're called to be a washing machine.
In order to feel alive, you
need to live life on purpose.
In order to feel
successful, in order for you
to gain prosperity, in
order for you to overcome
obstacles, you need to
discover your purpose.
Empowerment is one of those
words that's thrown around.
You have empowerment specialists,
people all over the place.
You see signs about
living the empowered life.
Very few people have explained
to us what empowerment is.
Let me give you this just simple
definition of empowerment.
Empowerment simply means that you
are back in the driver's seat.
Life does not have to happen to you.
You can happen to life.
Here's a thing.
Life comes at you one day at a time.
If you can just learn how to live
and manage for that 24 hours,
then 24 years will not be a problem.
When we talk about
empowerment, a lot of people
say okay, if I live the empowerment life,
what does that feel like?
What does it look like?
To me, it means that when
you wake up in the morning,
you already have a plan for
the next 24 hours of the day.
Then you're also able to deal with
those bumps in the road,
those turns in the road.
The times when you don't feel like doing
what you know you should do,
empowerment comes in handy.
Stop procrastinating.
Focus on your goals.
When you focus on what you want,
what you don't want
automatically leaves your life.
Don't focus on eliminating anything.
Focus on creating what you want.
So you're either going to
spend all your energies
eliminating what you don't want
or you spend your energies
creating what you want.
We all have alibis, we're all busy.
Busy doing what?
(audience member mumbles a reply)
I'm going to challenge you,
stay focused on your goals
and if you don't have
goals, write your goals.
One of the greatest enemies
of fulfillment of purpose
is procrastination and broken focus.
If you start now and you say
365 days from today's date,
this is what I want to
accomplish, and you do one a day,
pose that focus, this one thing I do.
I'm focusing.
You do one a day.
At the end of one year, you
will have made 365 steps
to one's fulfillment of purpose.
Who is not going to be successful
at the end of their life?
Who's not going to be prosperous
at the end of their life
if they can fulfill that?
Nothing, absolutely
nothing, is impossible.
You can begin again.
You can believe God again.
You can trust again.
You can be successful.
You can overcome your addictions.
You can heal.
You can feel alive again.
This is when you realize that
those things are possible.
You are getting a breakthrough.
So I want to encourage you right now,
don't give in, go for it.
Don't give up.
Don't throw in the towel.
Even if your back is up against the wall,
even if you are on the
ropes and you are receiving
a rope-a-dope financially, listen.
You got to fight back.
You don't get in life what you want.
You get what you fight for.
When you decide that my future, my health,
my marriage, my freedom,
my happiness, my joy,
my peace, my children
is worth fighting for,
you are securing your breakthrough.
When it comes to passion,
it's that thing that generates
either the greatest joy
or the greatest sorrow.
Passion to me is self-generated
and it's a self-generating
tool that you can use
when times of discouragement.
Your passion is going
to get you up out of bed
and is going to get you
hitting at the streets
and pounding the pavement
to bring that vision
to pass, that passion.
You have the ability to motivate yourself
and that's what passion is all about.
When you are able to
concentrate on your purpose,
to maximize your potential
and to live out your dream.
When you do that, you now hold the secret
right in your hand to living life,
not only on purpose, but with passion.
That's the thing that gets me
out of bed every single day.
The passion for what I do.
It gets me up in the morning.
It keeps me going late at night.
And guess what?
I end up going to bed very,
very seldom exhausted.
In fact, I always go to bed excited.
I have to tell myself,
you better go to sleep
so that you can wake up in the morning.
Sometimes I go to bed and I feel like,
wow, I almost don't want to go to sleep
'cause I don't want to
miss out on something
that potentially and
possibly take me further
into realizing my dreams and goals.
One of the things about passion
is that it's an attitude,
and your attitude sets the mood
for everyone and everything around you.
They get excited because you're excited.
Especially those people that
work with you and work for you.
If you are excited about something
and fascinated about something,
then people's fascination
and excitement is turned on as well.
One of the things that someone once said
and they said it like this,
"Chase down your passion
"like it's the last bus of the night."
This is what a guy by
the name of Glade Addams,
and look at his name, Glade, of all names.
He has the right to talk about passion.
What you concentrate on all day
long determines your future.
Now, here's the most important thing,
that if you are able to
concentrate your thoughts
one hour daily meditating,
praying, and thinking about
the person you intend to do,
or the person you intend to be
or to become, the places you want to go,
the things you want to accomplish,
what you want to invent,
create, the wealth
you want to accumulate,
the people with whom
you want to network, the
lives you will change,
the legacy you will lead.
You will literally create in your mind
a clear picture of the
inevitable, believe it or not.
This is going to fuel
your daily activities
as well as what comes out of your mouth.
I read somewhere one
time, watch your thoughts.
They become your words.
Watch your words.
They become your actions.
Watch your actions.
They become your habit.
Watch your habit.
They become your character.
Watch your character.
It becomes your destiny.
And it all starts with your thoughts.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Antoinette Pitts asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
check out the link in the description
and you can go and cast your vote.
I also love to know which clip
resonated the most with you.
What lesson are you going
to take from this video
and immediately apply to your life
or to your business somehow?
Leave it down in the comments below.
I'm really curious to find
out what you have to say.
I also want to give a quick
shoutout to Stephanie Noel.
Stephanie, thank you
so much for picking up
a copy of my book, Your One Word,
and doing that review on your site.
I really, really appreciate it
and I'm so happy that you enjoyed my book.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
- Now listen, success is a choice.
It is a choice to do something.
It's a decision, so if
you choose to do nothing,
you'll be successful at that, nothing.
But if you choose to take a
step in the right direction
and you'll be much, much closer
to achieving your dreams.
So are you ready to take that step?
This first step today to transform
your life into a victorious life.
I want you to take a piece of paper out
and I want you to list the major projects
that you want to fulfill in a year's time.
I want you then to prioritize them,
one, two, three, and four.
Then I want you, over the course
of three months, finish one project.
Not two, not three, not four.
Don't walk away from here without
creating that list, and then prioritizing,
and then starting now to finish a task.
You could start with small
things like starting that list.
If you start the list and you put
four things down, guess what?
You have completed your first project.
Give yourself kudo and
then go into the next.
It's great doing life with you.
I'm encouraging you to do
something so significant
that it will change your destiny,
positively impact your
family, your community
and an industry, and ultimately
the course of humanity.
What would history be
like if it wasn't for
the likes of people such
as Hans Christian Andersen
and Abraham Lincoln, Florence Nightingale,
Christopher Columbus, the Wright brothers,
Marco Polo, George Washington Carver.
What would this world be like
had it not been for the likes of Einstein,
Beethoven, Harriet Tubman, Joan of Arc,
Jean King, Winnie Mandela,
Coretta Scott King.
These are the people like Stephen Biko
who dared to make a difference.
Madam Guyon and Bishop T.D. Jakes.
Van Gogh, Steven Jobs and Walt Disney.
What would this generation be like
had it not been for the
likes of Martin Luther King,
Nelson Mandella, Mahatma Gandhi,
Mary the mother of Jesus.
These individuals refuse
to sit insulated within
the four walls of a building
or a church or a synagogue
just praying and wishing
the world was different.
They got up and they became
the change they wanted to see.
These are the people that refuse to see
themselves as victims of circumstances
or products of their environment.
You know one of the things
I found out is this,
that these people were just
ordinary in their own eyes.
They did something different,
something unorthodox
until they became extraordinary in ours.
That's what it takes.
You can not have extraordinary
without the ordinary.
It takes that to do something significant.